rest is productive if it increases your
work per unit of time over an extended
Horizon if I sleep eight hours a day and
I watch Netflix for four hours a day but
that allows me to work 12 hours a day
straight then those four hours where I
watch Netflix are productive in that the
other 12 hours my total increase in
output goes up if I work those extra
four hours would I get more work done
giving four more hours if my work output
drops to such a low point my answer
would probably be no because it would
not only decrease during those four
hours but then the next day I would not
have recovered and then my starting
point of output per unit of time would
drop so